vendredi on s'approche peu à peu de
l'heure de vérité au ps c'est jeudi que
les militants sont appelés à se
prononcer sur les différentes motions
avant le congrès de reims qui se tiendra
du 14 au 16 novembre
vous le savez quatre candidats sont en
lice pour prendre la direction du parti
hier on a parlé de ségolène royal et de
bertrand delanoë
aujourd'hui on s'arrête sur martine
aubry est sur benoît hamon qui
représente plutôt l'ailé gauche du parti
helen hughes mathieu régner voilà une
scène encore inimaginable il ya quelques
semaines au parti socialiste
les amis de laurent fabius et ceux de
dominique strauss kahn réunis autour
d'une même table et le trait d'union
entre ces frères ennemis
c'est martine aubry la maire de lille
nous sommes d'abord des socialistes nous
sommes ensemble nous avons eu des
parcours différents mais on n'est pas on
regarde pas le parti d'hyères on est en
train de construire solide demain c'est
qu'arnaud montebourg résume ainsi très
sérieusement remercier encore une fois
martin d'avoir rassemblé des
trajectoires différentes et disparate
des camarades qui se posait plus mais
qui sont mis à se poser plus dans
l'écurie aubry benoît hamon figure
montante du ps aurait pu jouer les
poulains une vieille complicité l'unît à
l'ancienne ministre des affaires
sociales dont il fut le conseiller
problème ils n'ont plus aujourd'hui les
mêmes fréquentation et avec d'autres
amis qui ont peut-être des positions un
peu plus radicale que je ne partage pas
est un peu compliquée que la gauche du
ps se retrouve avec des amis
benoît hamon fait donc cavalier seul
avec sa propre motion à l'ailé gauche du
ps
fils d'ouvrier la quarantaine un
discours efficace pour un peu on le
confondrait avec olivier besancenot est
ce qu'on laisse une boîte profitable
licencié à un moment où justement on va
se prendre dans quelques mois le tsunami
des conséquences sociales la crise
financière si on laisse c'est la cata
mais benoît hamon prône un retour aux
valeurs de la gauche tout comme martine
aubry incarne une gauche décomplexée
lenny fasciné par la gauche radicale
encore moins par la gauche molle une
gauche décomplexée qui ne retiennent
aucun de ses coûts à l'égard de la
droite parce qu' elle ne retient aucun
de ses coûts à l'égard des classes
populaires et des classes moyennes
nous n'avons pas perdu depuis vingt ans
des élections au plan national
parce que les français sont devenus de
droite nous avons perdu parce que nous
nous avons oublié ce qu'était les
valeurs collectives nous avons oublié ce
qu'était la gauche le vote des militants
jeudi permettra à chaque camp de se
compter mais ces deux là pourraient bien
en sueur s'allier au moment du congrès
auquel est la première côte